meet Ace Ventura it's real water there's
no in-between with this movie I mean the
characters way out it's very James Bond
did you know Jim Carrey wasn't the first
choice to play Ace Ventura rick moranis
actually turned down the role another
fun fact at one point the pet detective
was going to be a woman named Alice
Whoopi Goldberg was ID for the part he
was on the set of the film that turned
Jim into Hollywood's 20 million dollar
man Courtney Cox played the love
interest the movie came out just seven
months before the premiere of friends I
wasn't first choice for this movie but
that's okay give me we just got there
Gary thank you and then uh-oh that
pretty much says it all excuse me I'd
like to ask you a few questions this
iconic moment was based on Jim's comedy
sketch from In Living Color this photo
of footballer
ray Finkle was actually Sean young in a
wig and mustache and for this sex scene
all the animals had to be chained down
of course the squirrel and bird got
loose we had so much fun on that thing
that we thought we were just gonna end
our career every time we went to dailies
we came out going I don't know I can't
stop laughing anybody's gonna understand
this this is all I do I'll be happy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]